feltham beach bathed in spring sunshine
attracts all the attention a beauty spot
deserves
but the village is now in the spotlight
for another reason
whilst covert 19 infections across much
of the country are falling
this area is going against the tide
locals say the weather
isn't helping here is busy today as you
can see
however it was absolutely packed in the
summer last year
and i do think it does spread that way
there's people traveling 100 miles you
know even now
just to get a bit of lovely because the
uk is lovely isn't it we haven't seen
much of it ourselves
feltham stands out as an island on its
own it's one of a number of pockets
across the uk
which are being monitored closely as
restrictions are eased it's inevitable
but cases
are going to go up but if hospital
admissions and deaths
start to rise too it could threaten how
quickly
normal life returns latest figures show
cases have risen here by 142
and with more people shielding during
lockdown the work of this army of
volunteers delivering essentials to
those in need
is vital it means that it gets
busier because it means that more people
are isolated
and and therefore um and shielding
and therefore uh from our perspective
there will be more calls
in these uncertain times their
reassurance is proving invaluable
to those who've spent a long year alone
we're going to see people who haven't
actually
stepped out of their homes for almost 12
months now
and the impact and the fear
they have of going outside
you know they they see on the media they
they read about the case numbers
and they're frightened genuinely
frightened
experts say it's likely we'll need to
ride the wave of uncertainty a while
longer
these flare-ups will be commonplace we
are going to see
outbreaks crop up across the country as
cases get lower
those small outbreaks will become more
noticeable small increases can easily be
driven
by one or two institutional outbreaks so
for example if there's a prison in the
borough
or if there's an outbreak in a care home
or hospital ward that can
increase the numbers by a rate that
might
[Music]
push the numbers up rather than down
this area will remain under a watchful
eye
as england's deputy chief medical
officer pleads for the public
not to wreck it now the quicker
outbreaks are snuffed out
the closer we are to making happier
memories
[Applause]
sky news in west sussex